foreign
[Music]
hands
no no I never killed anyone
we were all marching we were on your
side
really
and which side was that
uh
side of the Vietnamese people
the people in the north of the people in
the South well all of them I guess
guess we all look the same after all
right
I mean I could be Vietcong for all you
know a spy
how would you know
I'm not of course I love America
[Music]
here in America we welcome people like
you
[Music]
sure you guys are refugees
what if I told you
that I
was a communist
undercover welcome to the world of
spycraft
we sent you to America so you could be
our move
but what happens to a mold when it is
suddenly thrust into the sun this is
current intelligence because we're down
here
what are you concealing I don't know if
I can go on like this
is
[Music]
oh how about this you work for me I'm
pretending to work for them your spine
encounters by at the same time your
spine right
let me get you all serious man you'd be
a terrible spy
[Music]
foreign